I was just driving it was in Israel I
was driving and I was holding my phone
oh and they're they're very strict but
like you can't even look at your phone
so yeah it's so weird out there it's
like you know when I was in Beirut
you know sometimes there's like military
there and they're checking thing was
it's a little it's much scarier the in
Lebanon than in Israel yeah yeah yeah it
is not as much in Israel
Israel's much more stable but there was
one day where like the I didn't want to
do a tour thing I want to stay in the
hotel and in Israel and I was like no
we're worse than me we don't do me today
like some sort of holiday or something
oh well so in kosher means you don't mix
the milk and are you not done with the
story no I'm done okay I was doing this
Cystic I agree with stop religious Jews
or kosher they don't mix meat and cheese
so oftentimes at restaurants they'll say
today is a dairy day or today's a meat
day that's what a why I think you have
cheese why don't they mix it's just one
of those weird it's in the Bible so no
beef stroganoff do you guys eat shrimp
stroganoff or what
you can't they don't Rogen off it no
it's no seafood like only fish you need
fish but no shrimp like lobster no wow
because they're bottom dwellers who
knows there's actually there's something
to that though cuz shrimp is the most
like biologically costly thing to eat
out of the ocean you're [ __ ] up the
ocean more biting shrimp yeah a lot of
people will guess that the reason was
that it was a lot of they say is
unsanitary that's what it is about pork
and stuff and that's why they cut the
dick off and think you know the
circumcised because it's cleaner yeah
but they do stuff like religious Jews
they put their dick through a hole and
[ __ ] their wife that way - no no what's
that
well they do glory hole yeah religious
glory oh thanks they put a sheet on and
just a little hole for the [ __ ] which is
I that's my fantasy to [ __ ] like that
you'd have to see my Halloween
you know if you did that you could [ __ ]
me but I were to [ __ ] like if you were
to [ __ ] me let me say scenario I will go
get to Brooklyn the sheet you would poke
a hole in it we do it beforehand
probably right I bend over
I stick the sheet over the hole where my
butthole is oh no what I would do is put
my dick through and then kind of do like
a what that sounds extra safe yeah
that's not but I think it's a challenge
it's very tough
yeah and that way um one of us needs to
see I prefer shuting first yeah why
would you want to put a hole in that
wonderful Brooklyn land
ride quality why do they do it why do
they do that why why do that why would
you explain that yet why'd they do it
that one buddy no why did I forget how
buddy no it's stupid
it was some really brutally disgusting
Jew he's like I got a nice [ __ ] but I'm
so nasty here's what we're gonna do
cover my body my dick goes to the sheet
I don't nobody has to face my awful body
Wow
that's in the Bible it is yeah it's like
what I heard like like men in like in
the Muslim world when they [ __ ] a man in
the bottle that's not really is that gay
that's considered gay that's right it's
just having a good time is this fact no
really you know Aaron saw documentary or
something on it you know airs one hour
was it a pornography but you know in the
Arab guys are they have a strange
tendencies were they it's not unusual to
see two Airmen holding hands they'll
just walk her out there buddy and they
hold hands oh really strange stuff but
if they see a guy sucking a dick they'll
throw stones at oh right right yeah yeah
would I you and I be able to hold hands
you think Gilbert I killed ran for how
long
long but what will happen is that you'll
be you'll start really oh my god he's
too comfortable then you'll try to take
it up a notch he was researching I was
trying to remember why the they put the
hole in the [ __ ] oh I think it started
from some star in the Bible where a guy
had to what was it have sex with like
the wife of his brother why cuz his own
wife couldn't bear children something
like that you and I like it has myself
handmade Stian in Gilead they repeat
this phrase where they say like when
so-and-so couldn't bear his own or
couldn't bear this guy's children his
brother offered up the wife why the
premise of The Handmaid's Tale is that
you technically give let's say we were
in The Handmaid's Tale yeah and I
offered you up to my brother Steve no
that's not how it works in in Gilead and
Handmaid's Tale they have designated
just to bear children yes they're
captured they're raped by their you know
commanders basically and they're only
that's all they're just carriage
basically that's all their body is for
and I think that that's that same I
think we saw I think we crack the nugget
oh no you know it's you know it's like
the worst thing about when I watch
movies I can't do rape scenes you're
sensitive to it I'm very I don't know
why but it's because of your own
experience no I have never thought I've
never really thought it through but it's
all rape
yeah yeah we're not a pleasant you know
pillaging right you can burn things down
I don't give a [ __ ]
one of the worst a yeah or kill I don't
care in a movie yeah but in when it's
rape I have to either like there's this
movie called irreversible and there's
like a ten minute
rapes in an in a tunnel it's so
believable I haven't seen it but I think
I've heard of it you've heard of it yeah
it's like literally a ten-minute rape
scene and literally like you watch it
just a second of it I just turn it off
and I walk away I hate it I took off but
skeet shooting there's something about
rape rape scenes or rape in general that
I find appalling I don't know I don't
know how many rape scenes I've seen in
movies Game of Thrones Game of Thrones I
was raped in Game of Thrones
Khaleesi was Lucy was Lisa was rape
that's right yeah also the girl was
raped by Ramsay right that was one of
those interesting raped scenes where she
should get she's in she gets into it
Khaleesi
she Avengers yeah I think that she was
she started to fall in love with the
possibility of having power overrode her
like this interest for the guy who raped
her
or maybe she understood it from a way of
like just the Dothraki this being some
like cultural thing rather than him
really beating like this rapist right it
was yeah you take on a wife and that's
what you did against her will I'm gonna
can I ask a question
you think rape is only shocking now I
mean it's probably been shocking all
throughout the history of mankind but if
it was prevalent five or six hundred
years ago when they were right when it
just happened when people like armies
would cut around right over soldiers
were going to a village and rape and
pillage right it's just a part of you
know noise or shock and then or you
think was always horrified like you hear
about the among the Mongols they used to
just [ __ ] rape everybody but yeah
it's awful
[Music]